Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Uh,
May 12th.
What's going on?
I am here at the,
uh,
all things comedy podcast studios.
Doug,
Stan hope is going to be here hopefully in a couple of minutes.
Um,
Doug was a,
had a late night last night at the library.
He was doing some,
some research.
Um,
you know,
a lot of,
a lot of comics like me just go on stage and we just,
you know,
as we call it,
shoot from the hip.
And the subtext is that of that is we don't fucking read.
And A,
I'll look who's hair he's here.
Doug actually researches,
dug Stan hope researchers.
All of his jokes making his way into the studio.
What's up brother?
At that giant Dr Seuss looking flower.
They stink of Bose and cigarettes.
Oh,
they do have a seat.
Welcome.
Wow.
Right on time.
Show up in this condition,
but put on your headphones.
Let's,
let's,
let's do this.
What's up my friend?
Is His mic on?
Yeah,
I don't hear it.
Ah,
Jesus.
Y'all think comedy's a fucking microphone.
Check.
Test.
Hey,
there we go.
Toad.
Yeah.
Just say my manager put the top down in his car and went,
as soon as I put the top down,
I could smell the booze coming off of you from the street.
Oh,
I don't smell it dude.
You're fine.
I was just,
I was just telling everybody that you were out at the library researching,
uh,
just doing,
making sure,
you know,
when you go to tell you jokes that you have all your facts in order.
I do.
Absolutely.
You want to chill.
You are one of the field.
There's occasionally I'll find some bullshit where I don't want to find it and I
don't fuck it.
I'm telling the joke anyway.
No one's going to know.
But for the most part I want to be right.
Is it anything worse than when you have a joke you love?
And then after the show,
an audience member comes up with actual facts that completely ruins your whole
point.
My most downloaded bit about winning pussy on a bed back in the 90s,
and it was a red sox twin's game.
Excuse me.
And uh,
yeah,
I got the numbers wrong.
Mo Vaughn didn't hit a home run,
he hit an RBI.
Some fact checker went back and found the game that I go into detail about and
it wasn't a home run,
but it's already recorded.
I can't take it back.
Oh,
it crushes you.
Yeah.
All right.
I was a bit wrong,
but the fucking red sox won and Bobby Barnett fucked me.
Well,
I love,
I just loved the fact that somebody can go back and find the Goddamn game.
Like then just and just,
just to be a car.
What kind of a who would care?
This is how Brian Hennigan,
he's my filter.
Uncut Scotsman,
manager.
Oh.
And and my ride.
Yeah.
We met,
uh,
when you were doing the,
the Wiltern you and now when it came down there and hung out.
Well,
uh,
what the hell did you do last night?
I tried to podcast with Marilyn Manson at his house.
Okay.
Last night into today.
So we have four hours of unusable footage or he's very open about what we were
partaking in.
I told her I want you to hear that.
Okay.
Two to what?
No Dude,
I am.
I'm like,
I don't want to get you put this out.
And he's like,
yeah,
I have no problem with it.
I get a text message on the way here.
You can't put that out.
Oh,
okay.
Well then let's not talk about what happened.
So you in Maryland playing board games,
you got to know you've got a little lost in it.
Yeah.
Monopoly.
One of those Parker brothers,
one's that just goes all night,
you know as it does.
And Bingo was supposed to be here with me,
but she took some of that board game home with her enough to put her in a
catatonic state.
Okay.
So I woke up after four hours of sleep.
She's,
we're in an air B and B,
the owner comes in,
he's talking to her,
excuse me,
is some Israeli guy and she won't even look at him.
She's that blown out of her gourd.
She actually was the one who texted me back this morning and I texted your phone
to make sure you were still coming.
She actually said,
Hey Bingo here.
That's how I know.
Cause she texted me.
Sorry,
I uh,
I answered your text to Bill Burr,
but I just took a pot candy while that probably not good on top of everything
else you've done.
Now you're taking medicinal marijuana when you're already psychotic through.
When is his TV show coming out?
I want to watch this.
You,
it's funny as a week would be a yeah,
I am on,
I'm on the exact opposite road right now.
I'm getting ready to do with special.
So I have been a fuck other than cigars.
I'd been a fucking choirboy and dude,
I,
I feel great in the morning.
He's behind on the podcast so I kinda hate being here cause I'm not caught up.
Oh No,
no.
And I want to open by apologizing to your listeners because if you're any type
of fan of the podcast like I am,
I fucking hate it when you have a guest.
Oh,
I'm sorry for being here.
No,
no,
no.
Come on dude.
You're talking about playing board games with Marilyn Manson.
My fans,
I liken this,
I hope they are,
I don't want to speak for him.
I'm sure though,
how you won,
do shunts on the Twitter.
I shaking his head always her head.
Always.
Always one guy that ruins it.
But yeah,
no,
I said I go this,
I'm such an anachronism right now.
He's got a Lexus convertible.
I'm an a leisure suit with a head full of cocaine racing here.
Just making sure I don't forget flowers for Nia.
Yeah,
your sweetheart right there.
Why would the,
why would the listeners not like you do what I got to tell you,
you're pulling off that leisure suit like,
like nobody's business.
He looked great.
That really is you.
Those things should come back.
I wish I,
you know,
something that whole fucking fad,
with uh,
everybody started wearing the bing Crosby Fidor is and everything.
I so wanted to jump on that.
I just don't have the head for it.
It would know the 70s is like this.
I'm so in a leisure suits and the dumb seventies outfits I watched like you
watch a slap shot.
The original one,
I was just watching the outfits.
They had the ridiculous pounds.
Paul Newman crushes a leisure suit.
Fantastic.
Hey did you know it's funny that just reminded me of was back in the day when,
uh,
you were doing that show with Rogan,
the man show you guys the originals,
you the second year,
the second home second when you,
uh,
Rogan had some fucking race car that he was driving and your parking spot was
right next to him.
So you,
you wanted to go out and buy the ugliest spot,
the biggest piece of shit.
And that's why the show sucked so bad.
Instead of trying to write better bits that we wouldn't even have gotten on the
air to begin with,
I just sit on Ebay and try to find the biggest piece of shit car.
I love that you find like a two door car convertible with fake wood siding,
80 dodge aspen.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
It was painted lime green with a white racing stripe and it was an unbeatable,
not even a convertible.
It was just had the top off.
So it looked like there's a top underneath the vinyl thing in the back.
Why did I even remember?
Would I just remember seeing it going next?
Nica was so fucking awful.
It was,
it was awesome.
And I had the props department makeup of bumper sticker that says I'm with Rogan
with an Arrow pointing towards his car cause he had like $120,000 Porsche.
So we'll get a joining spots in the lot.
So yeah.
Where did,
how did you find,
did you find it in California?
I,
yeah,
it was like Fresno.
It was a long road trip and uh,
the scariest ride home ever cause that things shouldn't have been on the road.
You know what I love about California is that you can find like those cars,
they live forever out here.
Like I saw a Chevy Monza.
Oh yeah,
I remember those.
I've seen like two chevettes.
I mean Chevy Chevette like you can't find those on e that they look for a
Chevette.
You can't find it on time.
They would like for the,
for the young people,
that was basically our answer to like the Honda civic was supposed to be,
are trying to get,
you know,
catch up with the Japanese people.
And it was made by Chevy.
It fucking died at 60,000 miles.
There was absolutely nothing cool.
My parents had,
two of them are 78 and 80 and uh,
I mean they were both gone in the crusher by like Ida Chevy citation for a while
on the road.
Sideways radio.
No.
Do you remember the year they,
they forgot.
They forgot to design a radio in there and then they will like fuck it.
And they literally turned it sideways and didn't even change the numbers.
My buddy had one,
I swear to God.
That's true.
Do you know how much that would sell for now?
Like what we used to consider a piece of shit.
Remember in Massachusetts they would have winter cars.
Someone would buy my romantic cat road,
but they'd have a winter car.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
The fucking t that went to car.
Right now it's self reg.
Eight grand if is in decent shape.
I know it's unreal.
Our childhood has worked with a fucking fortune now.
It kills me,
but I hate how it's all being sort of mocked,
you know,
like everything.
Like,
I,
you can't,
I can't wear,
like I liked when all those old school hipster tee shirts came out because I
actually liked a lot of that stuff until I realized that they were making fun of
it.
And then just maybe like,
yeah,
my childhood's a joke.
That's irony.
No.
Yeah,
I liked all those cereals in the Tang and all the shit that we grew up with.
Like I have a lot of [inaudible] I,
yeah,
count Chucky was the shit.
I like blueberries,
Zarek Srx Europe that you would pour in the water and it was only New England,
but it was a syrup you'd put into water and Zebra on the,
on the,
on the label.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
as good as can be.
Just remember that Z.
Holy Shit.
Oh Shit.
Where the fuck did that come from?
I have a ton of that since like the fucking seventies.
That was another thing.
They had all those,
Greg was dude,
it was all about getting hopped up on sugar and then watching these acid trip
can,
uh,
um,
like cartoons,
cause like all the writers,
the new generations of writers who were doing drugs.
And thought it was this hip thing and didn't realize,
you know,
cocaine,
the big lie,
everything that was coming in the 80s.
So they were kind of coming in the 80s.
Yeah.
They were kind of like steering you down that fucking road,
like to,
uh,
if you want watch cartoons,
right.
There's a shift somewhere in the late sixties,
early seventies where the older people are out.
If you watch this,
an old Flintstones one where they make,
and they're actually making fun of the Beatles.
Remember that one where they had that dead bug music now and book was,
it was a bunch of bugs.
It was supposed to be the Beatles and they like this song they was singing and
they literally was monotone,
like tone deaf.
They were just going,
yeah,
yeah.
He said,
yeah,
yeah.
We said,
yeah,
yeah.
And
then they'd scream like Paul Mccartney,
I want,
which is actually a lot of what the Beatles were,
early orange Lee overrated band.
You think so.
Love,
love me.
Do you know I love you.
Really?
That's fucking genius.
Yeah.
But that was the horse shit when they wanted the labels control and once they
got out of that it started doing drugs.
Yeah.
Robert's soul and fucking uh,
you know,
white album,
I think it was like the same.
They stand the test of time took on tape about the Beatles,
but the guy,
the,
the author was going into such great detail about how genius they were,
but talking about that dog shit.
Sixties.
Yeah.
You don't,
you don't like the Beatles?
No,
not really there.
Okay.
I got to Harold died.
I got to hear it.
I got to hear it now.
This is just,
this is a very unique,
I don't like music to begin with,
so I'm not the guy to talk to.
I'm just not a fan.
Yeah.
I listened to music the way most people listen to standup up.
Maybe once a year they go to a live show,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe I'll watch it initial what happened?
It just never caught on with me.
Mid intercept,
one of it's one of the fucking only good things human beings I've ever done.
I'm sure we had to chop down some trees to make all those guitars and oboes and
shit.
But I mean generally speaking,
just,
yeah,
it's not my thing.
I don't mind it.
Like on my iPod I downloaded a bunch of Basey and Duke Ellington.
Shit,
that doesn't interrupt your train of thought.
No lyrics,
just nice.
Does that help on music,
Doug Stanhope Music?
He doesn't mind.
I don't mind.
I mean if you have to have it on,
yeah,
as long as it's in the background,
I don't want to yell over it.
I don't want the words confusing.
What I'm trying to think about in a conversation or where when I'm trying to
write,
I remember being on a flight with you on American Airlines,
some random thing and I was uh,
you know,
I think we're both pretty hung over and we took pictures together.
We did.
Yeah,
we did.
And I remember that was when American Airlines,
when you went to go get off,
which start playing that music and their jingle and a thing and you,
you would've gotten a phone call and I was so hung over,
I forgot you on the plane and I just heard from three rows back your voice like,
Oh Greg,
can I call you back?
I'm getting air raped by American Airlines.
It's all these families there with children and stuff.
I'm just like,
Jesus,
this guy fights the fight from 8:00 AM on.
I don't have that kind of fight me.
I was just like,
all right,
I'll listen to it.
Just walking off like a Zombie.
You're already fucking,
you should have spent
that got signed on the dotted line.
Hey,
I got,
you know something when I was doing my three minutes of research that I had to
do on you,
cause I've known you for so fucking long and I knew I didn't have to do it.
I had no idea.
You've put out like 13 fucking albums I have.
Some of those are like,
one was like a XM radio's special event.
So all right.
What's your,
okay,
you got 1998 the great white Stan hope that's an hour.
I don't even admit that exist.
99 CICO CICO is most of the good parts of the first one I put out through a
piece of shit.
So we'll give you a one there.
2000 something to take the edge off.
2001 I said bootleg 2000 to die laughing.
2003 word of mouth.
2004 dead beat hero do that.
That's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven years in a row you took oh five off.
Put your feet up,
right.
Oh six morbid obscenity.
Now as a benefit thing for guys.
Long Story.
Okay,
so we'll knock that one off.
You still up to six or seven isn't all that fun killer?
No refunds.
I know that that's a failure because I saw that,
uh,
from across the street and Oh nine oh 11 is that also like Norway burning the
bridges to nowhere.
2012 before turning the gun on himself.
What a great fucking title and three Beer Hall.
How do you,
how do you judge?
What is,
what is porch beer hall putsch was a Hitler's failed attempt to overthrow the
German government in 24 and they'd all meet and beer halls and they'd Riley each
other up and just scream and yell about the government and all of this in a bar.
And when can you imagine drinking weed?
Hitler.
How much fun would that be?
Like just 1500 shares is just getting them all riled up.
Just be like,
yeah,
I don't know.
I kind of like juice and just to watch,
well,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Just the,
see I'll fucking magic.
And they always closes.
Hitler.
Hitler always get to close to get them all worked up into a lather,
but Hitler,
he goes up,
no Hitler.
What's my wave?
Hitler will go on whenever,
but no one wants to follow him.
Like that's his,
I'm not going on if that,
once he gets to work dirty to follow him,
you can't win either.
They either they don't like him and he just burns down the room or they there's
so into him he just can't follow the fucking gun.
Um,
yeah,
but he got them all to take to the streets finally to go over,
throw the government and a few people get shot and he ran like a pussy.
So that's the significance is I talk a lot of shit,
but when it comes down to it,
I don't do anything but it's just yell in bars is my point.
Isn't it amazing how back in the day,
how,
because of the lack of technology that you could actually assemble a bunch of
people in a bar and have them believe that they could overthrow the government
of your country or without a microphone.
Yeah.
Dude,
let's just walk down the street.
All right.
All of us and just what are you going to do?
Like what door you going into even fucking worked out how to get into the
parliament building.
Like,
what are you going to like the fact that they actually,
I know you,
they were shit faced probably,
but the fact that that was actually like doable,
like nowadays,
I mean the amount of fucking people as you were doing it,
like it would be tweeting like,
you know,
group over here thinking of taking over the government,
shaking my head away.
There's video of it as you went down the street,
they'd be like news helicopters shaking it.
They would turn it in,
do a fucking reality show before it even got off the ground.
The fact that you could actually do that.
But uh,
here's something I actually learned about Hitler when I got it was just on my
honeymoon over and we went over to France when I went to,
no,
I'm a fan of the podcast.
They listen.
How fucking I was detailed you so much at the beginning of that where you're
like,
I'm going to do all this stuff because I'm the guy that I would go there and
just find a bar.
The whole idea of France bores me just,
and you were so glowing about how much I'm going to go do this and that.
I always was only a small amount of time before you fell into exactly like I'm
going to go look at this fucking thing.
Like how long can you look at a fucking thing where three ob for whatever.
Yeah.
Here's what happened though.
I went up to the,
uh,
the Eiffel Tower and there was no,
the line was really short.
It's like pink's hot dog.
You go buy it.
If it's a short line,
you don't even want a hot dog.
You're like,
well,
we got to do it.
This is was fucking line.
So we went up.
It was totally worth it.
Dude,
I'm a contrarian.
I'm a grumpy cunt.
I went over there,
I put a smile on my face.
I knew if I went over there and I was my usual Douche and I acted like I was at
Disney world,
I was going to ruin my wife's honeymoon.
And why do you think I would ever hear the end of that?
It's not even that,
just to ruin that part of her fucking Douchey Nez came out that I felt okay
about myself.
Like what?
I would have been such a douchey over there cause oh no,
I wasn't.
No,
that was a sweet thing to me.
Like Rhode Island,
you're just a contrarion.
Maybe you don't like music and you don't like France.
I mean,
what else?
What else don't you like?
Let me guess.
You don't like Italian food?
I think it's overrated with the deliciousness.
I like the Spaghetti and meatballs and all those supermodels,
you know,
not really my style.
I mean you can kind of look at them,
whatever
I have.
Hey,
when we come back,
we're going to talk about,
well,
how overrated.
The blow job is.
Not a fan,
not a fan on a fan of the blow job.
Never really come.
Never really from the,
from the beginning or just because you're so tainted at this point?
Well at this point I'm worthless,
but even in my best day.
Yeah.
All right.
I feel bad for you having to do that.
Really?
Yeah.
What about what the fuck you want to do?
At least at jobs out in the open.
You got to sit there and like you're in fucking nom on point.
How many minutes are we in here?
I gotta I gotta read some advertising.
18 minutes and I got to,
I'm going to sell my soul here.
You have made this like you fucking up ads.
You don't fast forward through an ad.
You actually listened to the commercial because you fucked them up and it's
Alaria is that you're actually listening to ads like you look forward to the ad,
but I'm saying you could sell ad space for more money than any other podcasts
because Yo,
hey,
I have,
I have this thing that I do where I will fuck up and assassinate your
advertisements so badly.
No one,
we'll skip it.
Yeah,
but the sad thing is is I'm trying,
I'm actually trying to get better at this.
I like to think that I could be one of those news anchors on ESPN,
but I know when I read out these,
I lives as,
I could never would fucking hat I read the same way.
All right,
here we go.
Okay guys,
please don't look at me when I tried to do this.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Nothing feels better than that first shave with a fresh blade,
right?
It's smooth,
it's close and the blade is as sharp as it's ever going to be.
It's that goddamn damn it fills family.
You know what I hate?
Bill is going down to those Goddamn Walgreens or cvs and you have to stand in
line besides behind some junky just to buy my goddamn raisers.
Tell me about people are shooting at me with live ammunition.
How am I going to get a nice shave and you're just waiting for what?
Overprice blades.
Wouldn't it be wonderful if somebody recognize that problem and came up with the
solution?
Something I would not be a contrarian about.
I will appreciate a decent shame delivered right to my door or savior has come.
It's dollar shave club.
Uh,
where the fuck do,
I jumped too in the copy here,
but just a couple bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com ships me the highest quality blades you can get.
I'm a four blade guy,
evidently from the person who wrote this coffee,
they were in my head that looks like a four blade shave.
Okay?
Say it right off the bat when I say,
how many fucking blades do you need?
If it's sharp and with dollar Shave Club,
what are you gonna slit your throat four times.
And with dollar shave club,
it only cost share with a friend.
But for six bucks a month for a four pack,
seriously,
only six bucks for the best quality blades you can get.
So every week I can pop in a fresh blade and treat myself to an amazing God damn
shape.
Doug,
Stan hope joined dollar shave club.com.
Get amazing quality blades in the mail for a couple of bucks and treat yourself
to a brand new blade every single week.
Hundreds of thousands of guys,
uh,
with,
with have upgraded.
That's a typo from last week.
This is stupid.
They've upgraded from shaving with that old thing.
We're reading this stuff.
This is all off the top and I'm one of them and I'm loving it.
Now it's your turn.
Shave time,
shave money,
dollar shave club.com/burr that's dollar shave club.com/burr I mean that's
simple.
I think it's going to make these kids even softer with their timeouts.
You know?
I can't even believe they can grow whiskers.
All right.
Oh,
we should go to sports and we should go to [inaudible].
I know how the,
I know the format.
Wait a minute.
What?
You want to go to sports?
We're going to go to sports,
but I got to read a couple more of these fuckers.
I try to do half and half.
I'm trying to break it up like a great book.
Hulu plus it that he makes sense.
Hulu plus everybody.
You know what?
You've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch current season episodes
of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show and scandal and watch every episodes of shows like Nashville lost
and doctor,
who is that back swap with any of the red slash green color coded shows listed.
I wasn't supposed to say that.
These,
this isn't Carla coated.
It's in black and white,
I suppose to what shows do you like?
Doug,
what's your favorite show out there?
I hate music and fuck the Beatles.
Boardwalk empire is a of fantastic chentastic show.
You know what I'm going to say that Hulu plus has it that they do.
You know what?
I would be surprised if they didn't.
Um,
you get ad free movies.
How about friends and kids show up.
They have friends and Ross starts dancing around.
I love it.
And then shy Chandler makes a snide comment.
I'm now more than ever,
there's so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus to stream these shows and thousands more,
as much as you want,
wherever you want.
That's a terribly written sentence.
Hulu plus works on gear,
computer,
smart TV,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
play station.
Pretty much every streaming device you own,
you can even watch on your phone and iPad while you're on the train and at work
at the dentist or in the bathroom,
you can even block off a data bench.
You can do it wherever the hell you want to.
They even have original shows like dead beat a comedy about a pot smoking guy.
Oh,
talks to ghosts.
There you go.
Doug.
Binge on all 10 episodes starting April 9th.
Uh,
if it's only for seven 99 a month,
he gets all your shows anytime.
Any way.
How do you do it?
For Christ's sake?
Where the hell is it the whole week?
Just go to Hulu plus.com/norm what I'm trying to speed up through this right
now.
Sign up for Hulu.
Hulu plus dog.
Norm Macdonald.
Podcast.
Copy.
Slash.
Norm.
Yeah.
The city from norm.
This isn't supposed to be,
it's supposed to be slash.
Bill.
Slash.
They said norm.
You know what I like,
Norm Mcdonald.
Let's,
let's give him,
let's give him the money for the week.
Didn't even though he had a podcast.
Oh yeah,
dude.
Norm Mcdonald.
Did you see him on Conan telling that math joke?
No.
Yeah,
he got to see it.
No,
I haven't,
dude.
I'd like,
you know how many comics out there don't give a fuck,
but kind of still do.
You have to kind of still do to eat that guy.
Norm doesn't,
he's so free money.
What am I,
what am I best opening monologue jokes ever?
Did you ever see,
uh,
you know,
I remember that whole thing when he was doing weekend update and they told him
to make it funnier.
So he and he did and he just,
he just was more norm than next week.
Eventually of course he gets fired.
So then,
you know,
he goes,
it goes off into the Hollywood world.
He's got a TV show or hit movie or some shit.
So now they bring them back to guest host on SNL and he,
I'm going to butcher this,
but he kinda came out.
He's like,
yeah,
so I,
you know,
I get,
yeah,
you people now I got fired from the show.
So now they got me back hosting,
which means either a,
I got a lot funnier of this show sucks.
That's he opened up with and I know that that wasn't approved.
Sorry for the bad norm.
I'll have j Morton has to make up for,
that was a great norm.
Norm listening to norm on stern or anything,
any podcast listening to,
I don't know if you remember when Charles Grodin would do Letterman and just
knowing he's going on there that it was always a fucking great show.
Oh yeah.
What people didn't get that he was fucking around.
That's how norm is.
Anytime I have norms,
the guests,
I'm fucking listening.
Do you know there's a,
there's a Cha Charles Grodin was on SNL and there's a host sketch where he see
actually breaks character and is talking to Belushi and all those guys when they
have the be outfits on going,
I mean that the antennas are distracting.
He acted like he wasn't there for rehearsal because he was too busy shopping
doing this whole big Hollywood thing and they just make it so fucking,
I mean because awkward is so popular now,
a lot of people doing it in comedy.
Just to think that they did this back in the late seventies and a lot of people
the next fucking day thought that he truly skipped rehearsal and he was killed.
That was actually the sketch.
Like I,
I didn't know I d I think midnight run is one of the most underrated copies of
all time,
him and Deniro in that Charles Grodin is fucking absolutely brilliant in that
thing.
So there's one for you.
I Bet Hulu plus has that one to Hulu plus for only seven 99 a month.
You can get four blades dragged across your face as you watch,
you watch your favorite TV show.
So I got to talk a little sports his come on Michael.
Sam,
do you watch,
uh,
do you watch 'em and h hockey at all?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Do you tolerate anything in the playoffs?
I find it important to have a favorite team.
Okay.
And the playoffs.
Who's your favorite team right now in NHL?
All my teams are not in it.
Not Senators,
like the Winnipeg jets.
I liked like the Buffalo Sabres,
the Sabres.
I don't mind the Sabers,
but
yeah,
we went down for a minute.
Yes we did.
That almost never happens.
Your podcast.
I don't know if it just seems like,
you know what,
I'm just going to keep talking and if there's a fuck up,
you don't seem to fuck up,
but you don't seem to edit.
No,
I don't.
I don't edit.
I don't edit thing.
I just sort of do it.
Like right now,
we just freaked everybody out.
Like they were going 90 miles an hour in,
heading towards Nhl and then we just literally just went like,
Oh hey,
what the fuck this so sorry about.
Sorry about that mind.
Fuck for everybody.
No,
I don't edit them because it's work and I didn't get in this business to have a
job.
Right.
Okay.
I got in this business because I had jobs and they didn't like it.
I didn't like coming there and having somebody fucking going,
hey,
you know,
pick that up and fucking put it on.
I,
you fucking do it.
I know what I'm supposed to do.
You idiot.
I could mentally like all the fucking jobs I had,
I mentally could have done after the third grade.
So that was one of the things that pissed me off.
Like,
why did I go through all of that horseshit and ruining my summers and going to
summer school all those years in fucking high school and if this was what I was
going to do,
load and unload trucks.
Yeah.
Ups.
That was the big job in Wooster,
dude.
I got to say that was one of the most fun fucking jobs I ever had.
The health and boxes graveyard.
Funniest.
Well I wouldn't,
I didn't do ups.
Ups was like fucking,
you know,
it was like pledging a frat that you never got asked to join.
Um,
it,
it was,
no,
it was like a software company.
We're an intermediate between the people who made software and then they
shipped,
we had a,
all,
all of it.
You could be at all right here.
It was like before the Internet,
so we'd like this web page except it was a fucking warehouse.
So we suggest a ship it out,
bringing in ship it out and all that type of stuff.
But dude,
it was class clowns,
drug addicts and musicians.
That's what it was.
And then the people watching us,
we're nerds who wanted to move up the fucking ladder.
Like they wanted to get out of the non carpeted area and get into the carpeted
area and justify their tie.
That's basically what it was.
And we had the best that we fucking,
everybody had an impression of everybody there.
Everybody like had Nicholas.
The only impression I could ever do as my landlord in mass,
Massachusetts misdemeanors and I'd call my fucking,
it was a three decker and they call a guy upstairs who was a pothead and I'd
pretend to be misdemeanors.
Yeah.
Hey,
it's misdemeanors while you get it,
you're going to turn the heat anyway.
Fuck it off track.
You talk,
you talk,
you don't edit.
No,
I know what you mean with will.
So our boss was this guy and he had a regular voice until he got upset and when
he would,
he would always say,
he would go up a little and be like,
come on you guys,
Blah.
And we would all just go.
We just give them all of us.
So like he couldn't eat symphony of mocking as we were doing it.
He would always walk away shaking his head going bunch of babies and he would
just walk out.
And that was,
that was the worst.
We would get reprimanded.
So I never understood why anyone would want to go into the cubicle area where
now you were,
you were in this little fucking box.
Only one way in one way out.
They knew where you was supposed to be.
The warehouse,
you know,
I'm in the warehouse with a Fi's counting shit.
He's on the forklift.
No one knew where the fuck I was really supposed to be.
So there was an element of freedom.
It was just basically a bigger fucking cubicle.
So,
but anyway,
we got to get back to the hockey,
hockey,
the Sabres.
I was saying I would like them.
Um,
if they weren't in our division,
I still like him.
I,
I'm really psyched that they went back to their old uniforms.
That's what it all comes down to.
The Canucks fucking those beautiful colors.
I don't know if they still have,
they still have them.
They finally went back to him when they,
they the two biggest mistakes,
the biggest one was Vancouver's,
I mean it was so fucking ugly that home one,
that mustard yellow with the orange.
Did you liked it?
Well Shit,
you're wearing a leisure suit.
Tampa Bay Buccaneers creamsicles best uniform in sports history.
So yeah,
I liked the Canucks.
Nah,
the old Astros' Astros was a great one.
The old Astros was a great one.
Yeah.
When you were child,
you know,
we were talking about while we were waiting for the whole thing to come back on,
cause we,
we were talking about that Zarek Jingle,
how that came out of nowhere.
But then we were talking about other things like,
like fluffing up.
Yeah.
Like how would that,
don't even know if they make marshmallow fluff and there's no way that they
would,
they people have to,
they'll make moxie.
You can find that shit.
They probably,
but this note,
but fluff and other was mainstream.
Like in my neighborhood was peanut butter and fluff.
But I don't know if it was just a new England thing.
A lot of shit I thought was mainstream.
Oh no one drank moxy ever anywhere.
I never heard of that.
I've heard soda.
No taste is like,
uh,
I dunno.
It was like they Yeager Meister of soda.
It first hit your mouth,
it tasted like cola and then the head,
the most horrific aftertaste that just made you want to drink more to get that
first taste to get this second taste out of your mouth and then,
yeah,
then it was all legal.
It's all with do you remember can in my fridge at home,
I had it mailed to me.
Do you remember marathon bars?
They had this candy bar for the youngsters here or listening or whatever it
marathon bar was basically it was just a 100% caramel twist it around in like a
pretzel thing,
like a long stick.
And their big thing was,
it was so long as a marathon,
Barb was going to take you like a fucking hour to somehow consumed all your
fillings out of your,
and you'd sit there and like you literally had to bite.
I was like,
you're pulling a pin out of a grenade you had to fuck on.
Just rip the thing.
That was one of those questions where we,
what's that fucking,
and we had to describe the candy bar.
What was the name?
And it took us for fucking ever to remember.
Marathon bar bar.
Oh,
Henry's all of that shit.
Just anyway,
back to hockey.
I fucking hate me for being here.
Back to hockey.
So my Boston Bruins,
three,
three and two,
we're down two games to one now.
Now were up three games to two.
I still think it's going seven.
And um,
I think it was a bad move.
I'm Sean Thornton,
sprayed water at PK.
Sue on at the end of the game was just,
was not a smart move.
Like you don't rile up super hot on the heels of the whole clippers scandal.
You don't spray water on the old scandal.
Forget about what you know of certain percentage of the Bruins fan base.
When he scored an overtime goal in the end.
Word was trending on Twitter.
I mean,
dude,
you think you have vintage,
what's your leisure suit?
You should see some of the Twitter accounts of Bruins fans.
I'm so fucking embarrassing.
It's so fucking embarrassing.
It's so takes away from the game.
But a PK is quickly becoming a guy despite the fact that he plays for a team
that I hate.
You can't fucking hate the guy.
It's dare a Derek Jeter kind of thing where,
you know,
he was always a good player,
but now he's,
he's a legitimate superstar at this point.
And um,
he's just one of those guys.
He plays physical defense.
He can,
he can,
he's just,
he's got the whole defense thing down and then if there's an offensive time,
he can jump up into the play.
He came out and he came on my favorite goals of this,
this playoff,
and I hated that was against us,
but it was right as the penalty.
He was in the box.
Right,
right.
As the penalties.
It's like three,
two,
one and I'm thrown off.
Fuck,
he's coming out of the box and just the dude hit them in stride.
He went down there,
he looked like a Ford.
He didn't look like it.
Defensemen at all.
And a lot of people don't realize how big that guy is.
I went to a Canadians game earlier this year and he's fucking,
he's a monster.
So what,
having said that John Thorton and towards the end of the game and he's on the
bench,
he sprayed water in his face and it's just like,
why would you add?
Yeah,
those are crushing defeats and now you,
you,
you got this guy even more fucking motivated.
You mean he still,
when the game was over,
he still scored a fucking goal.
This guy is Freddy Krueger.
He's not going away.
He's not.
He's,
he's,
he's just going to keep coming.
So,
um,
I also loved the fine Sean Thornton got fined like $2,863 until the set really
specific thing like it was,
we tried to make it sound official.
What do you have cleared three grand if PK didn't have a visor on and it went
directly in his fucking,
I like is the cost of dry cleaning?
How is that what it is?
I don't know.
So anyways,
I think I actually,
I'm hoping we're going to close them out tonight,
which we could do,
but,
um,
I've watched enough hockey to know that there's going to be a game seven and I
think that they're really going to have the jump on us tonight.
I hate to say all of that,
but I,
I think already that they weren't going to fucking want go out on a limb and I'm
going to guarantee a Bruins victory tonight.
No game seven yet.
Said he had another reason why there's going to be a game seven.
I think.
Uh,
it's,
it's Romans Canadians.
It has to go say gay seven games,
four to two.
I'll even tell you the number.
Hey,
I hope you're right.
But I,
I,
you know,
the organization's to fucking what happened then?
What is it?
Fucking a habs the uh,
happy tons.
It's a French thing.
I forget.
Happy tons.
Like the habitats.
It's the French.
It was basically,
I think that that's the name.
And Americans before they,
uh,
the native North Americans before they did whatever they did to him.
I think that they called them that,
right?
No,
they wouldn't.
Why would they say that?
Because they didn't speak French.
I Dunno.
You know what,
you know,
that's one of those things I've looked up a zillion times.
Also,
like the Bruins logo,
the spokes.
It's supposed to be the hub or I can't have a fucking remember,
but I can remember the Zarek thing cause that's how fucking delicious it was.
All right.
Here's my podcast question before I forget.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Doug,
Stan hope has a bunch of Monday morning podcast questions.
We're going to go behind the scenes here.
When you,
you obviously when you read a letter,
an email from a a fan.
I have some right here.
Yeah,
we'll,
we'll get to one.
Obviously you haven't read it before,
but they're not random because you'd just get every third one would be,
what the fuck?
What are you playing?
North?
Andover.
So who does who prescribed?
Andrew.
Fabulous.
He,
he,
he pulls him for me.
He kind of knows the ones that I like.
And then,
so what I thought was,
I bet Nia does it.
I always thought that,
well,
no,
you don't.
You don't want to like,
I probably seem like you're in your basement and she's the only human being in
your universe that you can yell.
Ah,
fuck.
so I thought maybe she did it.
No,
she uh,
no,
she comes on the podcast.
She's had so couple of fucking great rants recently and I was kind of hoping
that I could get around,
but she's been a,
should be some real busy with her.
I brought flowers for a reason.
I go,
she's not going to like me.
Nia is not going to like me.
So I brought flowers to suck up the second she saw your leisure suits.
She's really big into fashion and she love it.
She would absolutely love,
but I'll,
I'll,
we'll get a picture.
Will soften the blow of Doug.
Stan hope by getting flowers and a nice picture of you in the League and the
leisure suit or anything.
Well it speaking about you gotta you have any more behind the scenes?
No,
no.
I thought if I come up with them I'll interrupt your train of what,
what color my pajamas are when I'm lying in there recording.
Um,
all right.
His,
let's,
let's read a couple of questions here.
Um,
this is from a listener,
a tug McGraw.
Remember tug McGraw Plays Ball player played for the Phillies,
used to slap his thigh with his glove when he not getting all amped up.
No.
Yeah,
when they were taken down your Astros or whatever the fuck they be.
Just like the uniforms.
Okay.
Sorry.
Okay,
Bill,
how about the NFL players suspended for smoking weed though?
I think it was a guy in the browns.
The guy like led the league and receiving get suspended because he was smoking
weed.
Um,
this guy says,
how ancient is that mindset?
Dear Nfl,
please let the guy who destroys his body for your rating smoke a joint to help
relax his body,
mind,
and muscles.
So he doesn't take it out on his girlfriend or,
or her kids.
Uh,
I love how he can't be married with his own kids.
Also.
Here's a great,
Hey,
you know what,
Michael Sam has brought us to a place where he might be beaten up.
His boyfriend after a bad game.
That duty just made out.
Like when he got signed to the rand drafted,
he got drafted by the rams and then made out with his boyfriend to celebrate on
national TV.
It was a beautiful day.
I was on Santa Monica Boulevard and I tried to high five gay men,
Michael Sam.
I literally tried to high five a gay guy outside of the,
out of the closet.
God though,
do you realize he's like not high five me bags?
It just went from fucking 1900 and the NFL to like fucking 2018 I think they're
actually ahead.
Um,
oh yeah,
I did not see that.
It was fucking beautiful.
I have to admit it.
I said home.
Is that a white boyfriend too?
So as interracial on top of that,
he fucking leans down and kisses it.
Small,
petite white man and celebrate his draft as a linebacker for the Saint Louis
Rams.
I gotta be honest with something and you don't,
you're not supposed to allow you.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to admit to your flaws.
He's supposed to act like I don't see color and I'm not homophobic.
I'm not homophobic.
I like to think,
but that actually made me uncomfortable thinking about that.
Why would that be?
I was site that he was going to be in the NFL.
Right.
And I also,
I also want a doorbell.
Knowing my also want,
I also want him to dominate because I was hoping he was going to play on my team
and he was going to dominate because it's a whole other level that it would know
the other team's fans,
like the homophobes.
It'd be annoying if he just fucking was a beast out there.
But then him kissing the other dude that,
that I was trying to laugh about it,
but it made me uncomfortable with,
but incredible.
But it was wicked good.
Like,
I guess I got some shit I need to work on.
I,
you know,
I guess I'm not used to it yet.
I,
uh,
I like to think I don't see color,
but I do,
but I don't see,
weight is a weird thing.
Fat People,
I'm off topic.
No,
I do.
I see.
Wait,
now I also see Carla at night.
I see color.
I ignite and ice was on fat people.
I don't notice when,
I never thought of that guy is fat till you mentioned it.
But yeah,
everybody sees color.
I hate when people say that I don't see color.
And it doesn't matter if you're purple,
red.
It's like,
now you'd fucking notice that.
I just notice that.
And you notice white people's singing in England and there's,
yeah,
I crossed the street.
I see it.
There's a group of,
fuck.
Hey,
you Asian.
I don't see color.
I can't tell you.
How are you African American.
Yeah.
I need to know when to cross the street.
And if there's a bunch of the same colored people,
they're probably looking for an enemy.
I don't,
I don't want to be it.
Yeah.
If the second you fill out numbered,
yeah,
we definitely sit down where everyone's white.
You Go,
well,
okay,
now I see where I'm going to be the enemy despite my color.
But I still see a group of the same color guy saw a bunch of white guys was
skinhead with shaved heads.
Right,
right.
Fucking football hooligans.
Yes.
It's terrifying.
You would be,
I don't see color or they don't see the danger.
I think accountants,
what do they do?
It must be dressed down Wednesdays.
No,
you see it and uh,
you know,
I don't know at night when fear comes up that you know,
you,
you think the worst ice do have been on my act,
that you know,
everybody's racist at night and you have to be,
and that's how you get home.
You just have to think the worst of people.
So you can make it to your car in the parking lot.
And whenever they are,
if they're Asian,
they were fucking Ninja.
Sure.
There are Chinese communist coming.
Oh,
it's just begun.
And I'm the first victim.
You have to think that stuff.
And then also when you tell these anecdotes,
you have to pick somebody like Asians so you don't get in trouble to certain
certain groups.
Certain groups get you in more trouble.
Armenians.
Yeah.
Talk all like if I used an African American or a Jewish anecdote there,
I'd be in trouble right now.
Dollar Shave club would be running,
would be running in the other direction.
Then we have more ads or are we going to,
we do what we do.
We didn't answer the question.
What do you think should show these show?
Uh,
the guide be suspended.
The NFL player for smoking a little bit,
but you know,
in the last 24 hours there was interracial male tongue kissing celebrate up.
So I probably didn't use,
it may be I'm exaggerating the tongue,
but they kissed deep and passionate.
Did move on,
hit a single or a home.
Right.
It was an RBI.
I say he knocked it out of the park,
but I was wrong.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
But yeah,
no,
I hope he wins the super bowl and he's the MVP and you know,
they have like their family and stuff.
I just hope he's out there.
Just just goes at it,
man.
That's going to be fucking hold on Disney world.
I'm going to a bathhouse.
I'll do.
Okay.
Who's going to be the first one to lose his fucking job or get fined?
Let's go down the rams roster and let's try to guess who's the first one who's
got,
oh my God.
Somebody's going to say something to think of a ram other than Sam Bradford.
Poor bastard.
Who's another one?
It's one.
What happened to the rent?
Mike Marks is what happened to the rams and that Shitty fucking day of one of
the worst stadiums like I've ever been to.
It's like,
it's like if the twins ship the homer dome down to fucking a Saint Louis and you
played football in it.
If there was a team that's coming to la,
it's the rams coming back.
They should.
No one gives a fuck about the rams.
It's like Delaware is a state.
You just forget that it even exists and the news comes out of there.
What's your favorite state,
Doug?
With favorite state?
You look at states the way you look at music for different reasons.
Yeah,
and I,
I mean I like Wyoming and Montana.
You just did that.
The red state tour.
I loved the fucking gorgeous out there.
It is.
But I don't tell people that.
Well,
I always say that when I always have the rosiest fucking outlook all years,
every,
every tour you do is great.
Every audience is fantastic as you know what,
because this is what I did.
I spent the first half of my life being an angry country,
sleeping on a futon and somewhere around,
you know,
approaching 40.
I was just like,
so this is the guy I'm going to be.
And I also,
I,
you know,
what I did was I kind of learned how to,
uh,
get out of my,
keep making that face.
It's going to stick like that.
Yeah.
My depressing downward spiral.
I figured out how to stop it.
Like,
fortunately I don't have clinical depression,
but I am,
I am geared towards negative,
cynical thought.
So what I would just do is I just just started thinking,
okay,
is that what you want to think today?
This is what we're gonna do this one fucking day.
Then I'll let new agey shit and I just started going to the gym.
You know,
I just,
I just started.
They don't,
when I went on the road I would do shit.
Don't you ever have a fucking horrible show?
Like one time I want to hear you come on Monday morning podcast is bill burr.
I just played Toronto.
What a bunch of fucking assholes.
No,
here's the deal.
But at this point people are coming to see me.
Yeah know.
So I'm going to get mad at them
that point.
If I have a bad show,
it's kind of on me.
It's like I come out and they clap.
Like I already killed for an hour.
So it's completely up to me to feel like this weekend I was in San Diego and um,
I was trying to put together one I'm going to do and I was a little off on a
couple of shows and when I got off stage I was mad at myself.
I wasn't mad at anybody in the crowd.
And,
you know,
it was a couple of drunk people and some people yelled out.
But like I never get mad at that because I think that that's what makes this art
unique,
that you can sit there and yell out at the person and,
and,
and you just have to fucking deal with it.
And I don't like that shit when,
if somebody yells something out and immediately they're going to go throw him
out.
Like I'm this precious fucking hope diamond or some shit.
It's like,
no,
I'm saying a bunch of shit up here that should make you go like,
dude,
you don't even,
what the fuck you're talking about.
So I mean,
the only heckler I don't like is basically if you're going to um,
talk and ignore it.
Yeah.
If you're,
yeah,
if you're just yelling to yell and you're not going to shut up no matter what,
then at that point,
I can still deal with that.
But I ended up feeling bad for the people who came out.
I put them in a show in Daytona beach a couple of months ago.
I don't know when,
but I had to throw a guy out from the beginning that before the show,
I'm watching this,
no way this guy is going to make it.
He's too drunk and he's out in the lobby and he recognizes me.
But you can see he's trying to focus and say words and I hide and then he's in
the front row and I'm like,
I Corsi is through this.
[inaudible]
was an old bit like it was so broke.
I went through the motions.
I know at some point he's going to try to talk,
he's not going to happen.
So it was like I would did a tired closing bit with the whole,
okay,
you're not gonna make it unless John Goodman comes in at the,
like at the end of the movie flight and it gives you bloat.
You went out on stage.
It's Roma.
I know what's going to happen.
So I just watched the whole thing.
It was fluid.
I would,
I caressed him out of the room like it.
Like it was a part of my act.
I had to go many times for being that drunk that I like.
I like it.
This should be on my setlist.
Okay.
Open with the thing about driving down here,
throw drunk.
I out segue into a retardation.
That's amazing.
I had a guy one time,
I was at the DC Improv and uh,
he was one of those guys,
like,
I'm not even going to say what he was doing.
I'll tell you off air because if I say it's you some asshole listening to this
is then going to do it.
But he was doing this annoying thing where he wasn't laughing,
he was doing something else.
So,
and I got into it with them and like whatever we did the,
we did the fuck.
Did he get kicked?
No,
no,
he didn't get kicked out.
So I go,
so I'm like,
all right,
so that's the one Yahoo for the weekend.
Cause you know you're going to get one,
it's going to be a fucking nightmare.
Right.
So the fucking very next night,
who comes walking in the door again?
The same fucking guy and the wait staff or whoever's seats,
some hears him say,
I'm going to fucking yell out all his punchlines.
And they sit them right down in the front row.
So now I'm going out there and I'm fucking riffing and I'm trying to switch it
up and blah,
blah,
blah.
And he yelled out the first punchline and I was so ready for it.
I fucking snapped.
And we ended up throwing him out.
And uh,
and the crowd was pissed at me because they didn't know the backstory.
They weren't there.
I remember this guy afterwards,
I'm selling my CD,
right.
And this guy comes up to,
dude,
that was fucking bullshit.
That's bullshit.
You're the headline,
are you and you should have to deal with that.
And I was going,
no.
And I tried to explain it and then he just wouldn't let me talk.
And then I said,
you know what you should do,
you should never come to one of my shows again.
That'll show me.
Cause it just got to the point of like,
no,
it wasn't.
It was like probably like six people who were flipping out.
But it was a,
and it was a classic thing.
They kicked the guy out and I'm standing there selling my wares,
whoring myself out,
getting to the end of the line.
I look up who standing in line,
that guy,
they kicked it out.
Like this is how comedy clubs kicked people out.
They get 'em an inch beyond the threshold or just the front door and then they
turn their back and then they go over and fucking,
or the problem have a,
put a some potato skins or something.
And then here's that fucking guide back in like,
so I had to tell them like,
hey,
in the future when you kick some ya can you kick them all the way out?
Can you make sure there's no,
did he say,
ah,
he was just going,
but we don't understand.
I love you.
You don't understand.
Like he was trying to say,
it was like,
dude,
you don't understand.
The first night he was trying to prove how much I love you.
Bye.
See,
I know every punchline.
He was,
no,
but the first name,
I can't remember which night we,
we've,
it must've been the second night,
but the first night we're,
no,
he was just trying to say that he was yelling up because he loved my stuff and
it was,
and he was just so fucking drunk.
There was no and dumb and dumb.
It's not like when he's sobered up,
like this level of fucking intelligence was,
was going to come back.
He was just a fucking moron.
And um,
it was kind of one of those things like that kind of person I had to kind of
burn off from my crowd.
Like when you first get your,
your,
your people finally coming up to see you,
your site and then that this people are going to come on and see and be like,
oh,
I thought he was this way.
He's actually that way.
And then they don't come back.
And then hopefully the rest of the room gets filled up with people who kind of
second youtube clip on a subject that they already have and they go,
oh yeah,
this guy,
they see it'd be clean on TV.
And they go,
oh,
there's a wholesome guy.
And then he come down there,
let that fucking,
and then they get up in the middle of it.
Now then of course you blame them.
Um,
all right,
let me do a little more advertising then.
We'll,
uh,
we got to wrap this thing up here.
Sure.
To do it.
I'm so fucking site just to see you man.
Cause I,
I never get to see you.
You've been one of my favorites sense since you had the long hair and you had
that head shot.
We had the fucking Santa Claus hat on.
I remember that one.
I remember,
I remember getting you a in the Chilkoot Charlie's in Alaska.
I thought it was,
can greenroom to [inaudible] had a band horns.
Yeah.
No,
and that was horrific.
But I always had an affinity for horror gigs like that and terrible
accommodations when they're that bad that they're comical.
And I,
Oh,
I thought you might think it was funny too.
And you're like,
I can't believe you sent me to that fucking place.
That rat trap.
I had to stay in.
I didn't mind the GIG.
That gig was fine.
The fucking,
that is the worst fucking place.
Absolutely.
Hating the magic at Burns on the television set.
The mattress literally was caved in in the middle and then when the fucking
covers were so ratty,
I just said I just have to make this my own.
And I laid down in it.
I remember I ran into Ralphie may Rodney make,
they couldn't put them in the band house cause the floorboards were too weak.
They had actually give him a hotel.
Is that what happened?
Because he said to me,
he goes,
I didn't fucking stay there.
He goes,
I took one look at,
I said I'm not staying here.
That they took,
they took one look at Ralphie may and when we can't put them in there,
he would literally go through the floors.
Yeah cause it was that big button though.
His lie gave me self esteem.
I just started saying,
I'm not staying here.
I need to get me a fucking hotel room.
I brought half the fucking rooms I stayed in.
You were there the week before and had done something with a midget and a
fucking God knows what.
Then you wiped the new John Fox.
Yeah,
you were.
You weren't like,
I loved you but doing the road so much I was starting to fucking hate you.
I was like this motherfucker,
how does he know where I'm going to be and gets there the week before and
fucking does something to the pillow case with his fucking Taynton ball bag was
horrific.
I always said the cure for aids was in the under the bed,
in the rug of a comedy condo.
Just the amount of band house in Alaska.
I actually took a bar of soap onto stage that was in the shower there cause it
had black mold and I'm like,
if you think I'm making up jokes about the band has,
this is the soap when you're growing mold on an antibacterial products.
That's how bad the fucking place was.
Yeah,
dude and I and I never went back.
I never,
if I went back,
let me,
let's do a little la advertising here.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Hey Doug.
Modern technology is great,
isn't it?
Smart phones,
iPads and other gadgets that make it so easy to do so many things,
but why is it that our lives seem busier at the same time?
Well,
when it comes to getting the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution that works with your busy schedule.
Hey,
let's trace it everybody.
The legal system is complicated.
There are better things you can do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you,
so if you're thinking about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a trademark will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you'll get person,
you'll get the personal attention you need and they'll help take care of all the
details.
Legal Zoom has been helping families and small business owners for over 14 years
and they received an a plus rating from the better business bureau.
Call or visit legal zoom today for an extra discount.
Enter bur bur are in the referral box@checkoutlegalzoom.com discount code
burpee.
You are are a legal zoom provides legal help through independent attorneys and
self help services.
But it's not a law firm.
Look at that,
Huh Dana?
They understand that I don't know how to read so they keep them short and here
we go.
Here's the classic everybody.
My Stairway to heaven,
if you will,
stamps.com
there's a stamp.
Who knows are back in the days of black and white TVs and phones in Wa with
wires.
The only way for a business to avoid the post office was the least a postage
meter.
Technology has changed dramatically since then,
but those posters,
postage meters haven't.
Luckily there's a way better way to get your postage stamps.com with stamps.com
you can do so much more than a postage meter for so much less.
Get official US postage for any letter and any packages using your computer and
printer,
no hardware to buy or lease.
And unlike a meda,
there are no long term commitments you can save up to 80% versus a meter plus
with stamps.com you can track packages,
track spending and more.
I have to take off right now,
Bill,
because I have to get to the post office to mail my rent check.
Well,
why would you do that when there's a better option?
Is there a better way?
It is.
It's called stamps.com you can print legal postage stuff with a meter right in
the comfort of your own home right here.
Yeah.
You and Marilyn Manson last night when you're in the middle of weeding legal,
zoom.com can settle a libel suit.
When Marilyn Manson comes out and he's going,
why would you mention coke on the air?
No,
but they could trademark that.
That argument right now,
use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial or norm or norm plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to $55 free postage.
What Marty want here,
people don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
birth.
All right.
Hey,
speaking of digital scale,
how much is my nose worth right now?
Excellent.
Doug.
You know what?
Of course,
the week you fucking come in.
I only got like that.
That's,
sorry,
I,
I'm a wreck.
I smelled bad.
I email myself.
Well,
I can't tell you don't come much closer to the Raytheon of Europe's outfit.
There's holding your,
your to go do Burke crushers podcast.
He goes,
I hope you're not on the wagon when you come through my podcast,
so I guess,
hey,
tell Bert like a,
and we were supposed to smoke cigars a long time ago.
I got a bunch of Cubans in my Hubris humidor.
If he wants to smoke,
I would love to.
I'd love to hang out with them and a dude,
I fucking love you to death,
man.
It's so great to see you.
I wish you lived in La,
man.
I really wish she could come in more often.
Wait,
what?
Yeah,
you are out in Arizona,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
We know what happened.
Weird place.
I'll buy an experimental aircraft.
I'll get out there.
Crash land on your front.
Fucking cactus.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
The one and only Doug Stan Open.
If you're brand new to this guy,
I'm telling you,
man,
this guy is one of the greatest comedians I've ever seen.
Definitely without a doubt.
One of the best of my generation.
Then in a long time,
dude,
I know you don't like feel the same way about you serve compliments.
Well,
you know something at some point,
dude,
we ought to try to do a,
we had to try to do a co headline things somewhere.
It's something random.
Vegas is always the place to do that because you know I burned and a fan base.
Everyone's from out of town and you can,
yeah,
some reason I want to go to yellow knife.
I don't know that.
I'd rather do that.
Why don't we do that?
Weird.
Yeah.
Yukon territory.
You didn't go there on your Canadian tour,
so yeah.
Fuck.
Why don't,
why don't we do a one off up there?
Yeah.
See what roughneck oil workers Escobar run into.
I'm going to go to some random place,
the middle of fucking nowhere.
I'm in and do like a three hour show.
All right.
You're up for it.
All right,
Doug.
Stanhope everybody,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Go Bruins.
Okay.